devant des retrouvailles inespérées
Irina ne pensait jamais revoir son fils
bodgame
ne peut pas imaginer comment c'était
d'être sans toi pendant 6 mois lui
dit-elle incapable de le lâcher je me
demandais comment je pouvais te ramener
en Ukraine
botgun fait partie de ses enfants
Ukrainiens déportés en Russie depuis des
territoires occupés par Moscou comme
karkiv et Kerson
je n'ai jamais cessé d'écrire à ma mère
dit-il mais la connexion internet était
mauvaise elle m'a tellement manqué
par l'association save you crane et
après un long périple de 5000 km et on
interrogatoire de 13h par les services
de sécurité russe ces mères ont pu
récupérer leur enfant en passant
notamment par la Pologne et le Belarus
pour entrer en Russie c'est un appel
téléphonique de l'un d'entre eux qui
s'est souvenu du numéro de sa mère qui a
permis de localiser les 31 enfants
rescapés
ses enfants ont changé de lieu Sting
fois durant les cinq derniers mois
transférés d'un camp à l'autre explique
le président de l'association les
autorités de Kiev estiment que près de
20 000 enfants ukrainiens ont été
déportés en Russie depuis le début de
l'invasion de leur territoire 24 février
2022 dont plusieurs auraient été placées
dans des foyers d'accueil parce que pour
sa part ni ses allégations
l'affirme plutôt les avoir sauvés en les
éloignant des combats et avoir mis sur
place des procédures afin de les réunir
avec leurs familles le mois dernier la
Cour pénale internationale a émis un
mandat d'arrêt contre le président russe
Vladimir Poutine et sa commissaire à
l'enfance Maria vova Belova présumé et
responsable de crimes de guerre et de
déportation illégale de mineurs
ukrainien vers la Fédération de Russie
ici Daniel Kadjo Radio-Canada Montréal